big update now tagashi has tweeted again
with our very first shot of new hunter
hunter we also have a confirmed number
of chapters being published and it is
more than four plus even more stuff
because after three years of starvation
we are finally starting to eat some good
but togashi has posted our very first
image from a new hunt hunt manuscript
and it is a tree which sounds kind of
mundane but if you are familiar with the
series and where we are right now then a
tree is anything but it's actually quite
unusual currently we're stuck in the
middle of the ocean on a round
whale-like ship so trees are a thing
that's kind of surprisingly hard to come
by so for the first time at least i
recall in human history an image of a
fictional tree set twitter on fire with
speculation that this could potentially
be an image from the dark continent
itself or perhaps even whale island
where gone currently resides or even a
shot from the zoldic estate on kukuru
mountain it could be almost anywhere
anywhere that isn't a big ship on big
water although it could also be that as
well because this is hunter hunter
nothing is impossible and this could
easily be a short flashback or even the
result of a nen ability like say melody
whose musical powers are depicted with
illusions of nature in any case it's
pretty impossible to predict exactly
what this is but what i'm more impressed
by is that togashi is actually drawing
this more background atmospheric sort of
image usually this sort of stuff was
handled by his assistants because it's a
lot of tedious line work that togashi
just well he just wasn't physically
capable of due to his condition but
speaking of some of the best news we
have here is togashi's assistant
confirming on twitter that there will be
at least 10 countum 10 chapters of
hunter hunter implying that they will
start being released when the 10
chapters are made which is a lot more
than standard typically mangaka work
anywhere between two to four chapters in
advance for weekly series that is so i
imagine that waiting for those 10 is a
way of giving us that bit of extra
leeway should togashi need to take
things extra slowly and probably one of
my favorite things in in the ever were
the reactions of megami han and maria
issei the voices of gon and killua who
both elected to post some simple yet
emotional drawings of their respective
characters and i do think that crying is
appropriate because of all of the
characters who are likely to appear in
this new batch of chapters gone and
killua are not two of them but i also
asked what your predictions were for you
hunter hunter so let's kick into that
with um there are so many possibilities
but i hope we see more of the phantom
troop and zodiacs interacting that
excites me which is a very specific and
undeniably exciting desire in fact to
date we've only seen one interaction
between mizei storm illumi and kalato it
is fairly inevitable though except for
the ones guarding beyond netro most of
the zodiacs are stationed on deck 3.
which just so happens to be where one of
the major mafia families is also
stationed but also the goal of the
phantom troop is to completely sweep the
ship in their hunt for hisoka but given
that the hunter association had been
charged with the security of this entire
ship it does feel like a potential
conflict where the zodiacs could be on
the cards or even a potential alliance
there may be a situation in which the
zodiac see more value in allowing crollo
and his bunch of crawl-awaits to quell
some of the trouble aboard the ship
because the troop are already very much
embroiled in the mafia stuff to varying
degrees so look essentially what we have
brewing here is a great big effing mess
idk win but i would like to eventually
see a time skip in the story that takes
place after all of the passengers board
the black whale go mysteriously missing
and then kilowatt and gone reunite to
look for karapika and leoria so that
would be a really bold way to kick off
this set of chapters to completely cut
away from the succession war have it be
like six months after the blackwell one
sets sail and then gone receives news
that all of his friends have vanished it
would be a reasonable way to inspire him
back into action no no nen i don't know
though i just
i don't want gone involved in this he's
a tricky character and his personality
doesn't really fit into what togashi is
trying to create here with this very
politically charged arc which is all
about the dynamics of global powers and
even the inner conflict within one
particular kingdom whereas gone should
be off doing other gone things like
homework and catching fish i got a
feeling that the next 10 chapters might
wrap up almost 80 percent of the
succession war arc that would be crazy
and yeah this might sound ridiculous but
i definitely wouldn't count it out every
time tagashi comes back from a long
hiatus it becomes very apparent that his
priorities with storytelling have
changed the ideas that he was exploring
a few years ago might not necessarily
interest him anymore and he'll be
captivated by the thought lust of
exploring something new and relevant to
where he currently is as a person
because for better or worse hunter
hunter is it's actually a very selfish
story tagashi doesn't necessarily draw
for his readers as much as togashi draws
for togashi meaning that if all this
time has passed takashi's scene sees
native game of thrones and has simply
become bored of the throne war concept
then i can absolutely see him wrapping
it up swiftly and moving on to whatever
the next thing is i mean he did this
with classic hunter hunter more or less
just ending arcs not necessarily when
the story was done but when he was done
personally i guess i would describe
tagashi as a kind of narrative tourist
he likes to get there see the sights but
very rarely does he stay to fully
explore the stories he set up i would
like to see les audio with op medicool
ability on the dark continent he
definitely needs his time to shine and
yeah i would be as well i don't know if
i'd bet on it though i think that the
best thing we can say about leorio right
now is that he's there since setting
sail lyorio hasn't actually done
anything except hanging around in
cheadle's medical ward and he's quite
powerless compared to the sheer insanity
going on around him but at the same time
that's probably where his great
potential is i like that one of our main
characters is for all intents and
purposes just a dude and in particular
he serves as a necessary counterbalance
for karapika you could maybe even equate
leorio to being like karapika's killer
just as killua was there when gone was
engulfed in darkness lyorio could be
there for when karapika does ultimately
snap and you know if anything without
lyorio i'd say that krapika had a near
100 chance of not returning from this
voyage i'm excited to see what theta
will do next
i'm not because as badly as i feel for
caropika right now
at least he has a chance with data she
has a very very dark ending in coming to
her credit very few people live this
many days in such close proximity to
fourth prince nick especially if they're
female i mean usually by now he probably
would have sliced her up and made some
sort of grotesque art piece out of her
corpse but the main thing is the
guardian spirit beast ceradnix beast
operates on a three-strike system every
time someone lies to ceradnik that is a
strike and theta has now allied twice
and was also warned that the next time
she did it she would cease to be human
and i feel like as terrifying as it is
we we need to see that third time we'll
be getting a chairman netero into the
dark continent flashback yeah i suppose
that's another one of the like infinite
explanations for takashi's tree and look
i wouldn't be complaining like at all
netero has been to the dark continent
twice and we've only seen a tiny tiny
sliver of one of those occasions
although i'm not entirely sure what we'd
achieve by going back to that firstly
because we are so balls deep in the
succession war that focusing on the
wider dark continent does seem like a
big shift however as i said it's
entirely possible because hunter hunter
is all about what togashi wants to do
traditional rules of storytelling be
damned i think what i would rather see
is a flashback of beyond's journey to
the dark continent purely because i just
want to know more about him and his
motivations he is so stupidly
captivating the theory that hisoka is
illumi yes yes yes i won't dive too
horrendously deeply into this because
i've already made quite an extensive
video about it but in case you're
unaware the leading thought regarding
hisoka right now is that he is indeed
aboard the ship but that he has used his
new bungee gun powers to imitate illumi
and i know just like the stupid gum
itself this sounds like a bit of a
stretch but the evidence for this idea
is simply too overwhelming to ignore
there's very simple things like illumi
acting out of character even when it
comes to his chosen pronouns because
curiously enough he's adopted a lot of
hisoka's speech patterns as well as some
of hisoka's fashion sense with the knee
pads and everything hillary has never
worn knee pads before now hisoka on the
other hand is a kneepad pro and there's
also the fact that togashi has more or
less very sneakily confirmed it on the
cover and author comment of volume 36
and if you want to know more and like
there is so much more to know then i
highly recommend you watch this video
because if you've never heard it before
this theory will completely change the
way that you see the current arc my
prediction is for hunter hunter that we
will be seeing more hiatuses
yeah so quite a few of you said
something along these lines and okay
you're not exactly wrong the bittersweet
truth is that this is not going to be a
full return to form and there never will
be in fact it's become very common to
see togashi produce a batch of 10
chapters and take another hiatus
although not usually as long as the one
we've just endured but yeah before our
big three-year drought the pattern was
something like publish ten chapters six
month hiatus another ten chapters vanish
for six months and so on and so forth
which i suppose was bearable because at
least that meant that we were getting
hunter hunter once maybe twice a year if
we were lucky so i honestly wouldn't
expect more than 10 chapters before our
next hiatus but hey the great thing
about the number 10 is it's more than
the number zero so it's gonna be a
pretty solid three months or so while it
lasts beyond does something insane
paristan does something douchey and
saridnik does something artistic i don't
think that the three of those are
mutually exclusive i feel like
everything that beyond paristan and
ceridnik do are simultaneously insane
douchey and artistic i suppose someone
we haven't touched on yet specifically
is paristan though because we're still
very much waiting to see how he jing and
the rest of the beyond expedition team
are actually planning to arrive on the
dark continent because they could be
aboard the blackwell one but we've not
been given any indication that that is
indeed the case with his connections to
the kakian empire i'm sure that beyond
could have used some king power to sneak
them in however one thing that's always
stuck in my mind were steiner's words
about how humanity has never officially
made a round-trip to the dark continent
without the gatekeeper and the guide
very much implying that unofficially
someone has and that there is a
potential different way to get there but
then again if beyond's team did know
about that then why did he go to all of
the effort into manipulating pretty much
the entire world to craft this
expedition questions so many questions
the clash the troop is finally getting
involved and killing the third prince
chrollo is stealing that ability the
other princes are also something we
haven't really spoken a lot about in
this video so the third prince being
referred to here is zenglai who doesn't
actually have a nan ability and he's
actually one of the princes who was
unaware of nen before the succession war
began although right now he does have
his funky guardian spirit beast which
allows him to produce coins that do
things and i'm sorry about how vague i'm
being there but even zhang lay himself
is pretty unaware of their abilities at
the moment and as for crowler that
brings up an interesting question over
whether or not he's actually capable of
stealing guardian nen beasts i think the
biggest problem in that regard is that
most of the princes don't understand how
their beasts function or how nen
functions actually because one of the
requirements to steal an ability with
skill hunter is to ask the victim a
question about then and have them answer
so most of the princes are kind of
weirdly immune from crawler at the
moment due to their sheer ignorance of
men but i do think it would be very
interesting for crollo to steal a spirit
beast we will see more videos from new
world review yes yes you will in order
to make sure that people are ready for
the new chapters i'm currently planning
a series of dark continent succession
war recap videos because there's just
like there's so much to know tagashi has
gone full force with characters plot and
world building to the point where i
definitely don't expect anyone to
remember what they were actually reading
three whole years ago so yeah look
forward to that